that progress has been
a success of our nhs vaccination program
by the huge scale of our testing
and by the sheer sacrifice and the
discipline
of the british public and so it's
important
that we don't put that success and
undermine it now by putting it at risk
getting a vaccination feels like being
given your life back
newly vaccinated thanking their
wonderful volunteers
people in tears of relief but
as well as the joy there's also concern
about resurgence of
covid and it's a caution we absolutely
share
as a government and it's why the only
route out of this pandemic
is careful and prudent a responsible one
of course we're also as a nation a
group of people who thrive on travel a
nation with
family ties across the globe notably
nearly one in three new mothers in the
uk
was born overseas and in 2019
uk residents took over 93
million trips abroad so
i'm glad to be standing here today
announcing
the first albeit tentative steps towards
unlocking international travel we want a
summer in which
with the help of vaccines and testings
we can
reunite families and friends travel to
places
we love we want to start looking outward
again whilst covered has isolated us
travel reunites us even if video calls
have
kept us all connected during the very
long lockdowns
there's simply no substitute for human
contact
travel is of course also absolutely
crucial to rebuilding
our economy bringing long-awaited relief
to
hard-hit airlines airports the tourism
sector
which taxpayers have spent seven billion
pounds
in supporting but i have to be
absolutely straight with you our success
in
combating covid here with two-thirds of
adults now vaccinated is not yet
replicated in many places abroad
we in this country have managed to
construct a fortress
against covert but the disease is still
prevalent
in other parts of the world most notably
at the moment
in india in fact more new cases
of covid have been diagnosed around the
world in the last seven
days than at any time since this
pandemic
began nobody nobody
wants to go back into lockdown not ever
and that's why today's announcement
removing the stay in the uk restrictions
from
the 17th of may is necessarily
cautious we must make absolutely sure
that the countries we reconnect with are
safe
that their infection rates are low and
that their
vaccination rates are high it means
making sure
that we're not incubating the most
dangerous variants that they're not
and that they have safe and secure
surveillance in place
and that's why the global travel task
force
has come up with the traffic light
system classifying destinations
by risk and this is based on data by the
joint biosecurity center and it will be
published
on gov dot uk red countries
are those which should not be visited
except in the most extreme
of circumstances where repeated testing
and isolation in designated government
hotels on return
is compulsory non-uk residents have been
been in a red country in the last 10
days will still be barred
from entering the uk i have to tell you
now that due to concern about covert
rates and variants of concern
turkey the maldives nepal must
regrettably be added to the red list
today
countries form the biggest group as with
the red list
you should not be traveling to these
places right now returnees will
have to do tests on three separate
occasions once before departure twice
after arrival
and isolate in a place of their choosing
for 10 days
finally we have the green countries
which you will have the opportunity to
visit no earlier than the 17th of may
as long as you take a pre-departure test
before returning to
england and a second pcr test two days
after you return and with these green
countries you will not
need to quarantine and travelers will be
glad to hear that we've been successful
in driving down
the cost of tests however by necessity
this initial green list must be i'm
afraid limited
so i'm announcing today that from may
the 17th you'll be able to travel to 12
green list countries and territories
which includes
portugal gibraltar and israel
i regret the favorite summer
destinations like france and
spain and greece are not yet included
but every three weeks from reopening
we'll be reviewing the countries
uh to see how and where we can expand
the green list so
this is just a first step the signs
overseas are now more promising as a
result of their vaccination programs
beginning to crank up
and as the summer progresses we hope
that more traditional tourist
destinations
will be unlocked but we have to turn the
key slowly
and greenless countries will be placed
on a watch list
if we start to have any concerns and
if it's necessary because of a new
upswing in cases or
a new variant will not hesitate to act
fast and
withdraw green status
so it's up to you to check thoroughly
before traveling
and if you're thinking of booking a
holiday in a green list
destination please check the
restrictions applying
to new arrivals you can get this
information on gov uk
and it is important because each country
has its own restrictions
indeed our strong advice is not to book
any holiday which does
not include a refund in the event that
the covid
related situation changes and you're
able to cancel
and i'm afraid we do expect longer
delays at airports and
paul will be saying more about this in
just a moment
but all these measures are necessary to
protect us from
new variants and guard against a
resurgence of
infections and that is why the uk has
now developed the most
comprehensive testing regime on the
planet testing
up to 2 million people per day
mobilizing our
world leading genome sequencing to spot
mutations that could lead to new uh
variants
and these are if you like the walls of
our fortress
because the first duty of any government
is to preserve the safety of its people
but it's also our responsibility to show
global
leadership to work with other countries
to create safe standards
for international travel these were the
issues i discussed with the
g7 transport secretaries when i chaired
a meeting
with them earlier this week i was able
to set out
our own traffic light system as part of
international leadership the
government's working to develop these
standards
global standards for digital travel
certification
so from the 17th of may english
residents will be
able to use their existing nhs
health app to gain access to their
vaccine
records alternatively they'll be able to
request a paper
letter to verify the vaccination status
now before i finish let me make one
final point
i know that there are many people
watching who might want restrictions to
be
lifted faster and to go further and
there are
if anything more people who prefer us to
go at a slower
pace what what unites us all i think is
the belief that
we don't want to return to the days of
misery and suffering and
loss and we must keep our fortress built
at such a
huge cost to all of us secure
until brighter days when unrestricted
travel
will allow us to meet people who mean
the most to us
for now we must tread carefully
respecting
the science that will guide us along the
way
i'd like now to turn to jenny to cover
the epidemiological
situation jenny thank you secretary
could i have the first slide please
so i'm just going to talk through four
slides which gives the
epidemiological picture across the uk at
the moment
and what we see here is the number of
people testing positive for covid19 in
the uk
um thankfully the new cases have
continued to decline
right across all four nations and you
can see that from a peak at the start of
the year around sixty thousand cases
um our latest figure is 2060 and that's
actually a decline
of just over 300 from this time last
week
and and the case rates per 100 000 which
have been up in the hundreds
are now down on average to 23 per
hundred thousand
there is some variation across the
country and there is an element of
plateauing here
and positivity is plateaued at around
0.8
next slide please uh then moving on to
hospital data and what you'll see is
that as we know the curve
shifts a little bit to the right people
tend to be hospitalized
slightly later about two weeks into
infection um
and again in the uk hospital bed
occupancy for covered 19
patients peaked around the middle of
january at around
39 000 beds in usage and since then it
has continued
to drop dramatically so hospital
admission rates now
overall are just above one per hundred
thousand one point naught four
uh in the last week with again some
variation
across the country uh all uk nations
have seen that decline in hospital beds
and we have a decrease of 19
in the preceding week so currently we
have uh 1231 people
uh in hospital with covid but again just
to note that that very rapid decline
is plateauing slightly as we go into may
next slide please
so here we have the number of deaths of
people who had a positive test result
for
covert in the uk again if we look back
we have moved from a very sad position
in january
to where was well over 1 000 deaths per
day associated with covid
and we're now down to the most recent
seven day
average at just 12 deaths per day now of
course
every one of those is important and a
significant loss
but this shows a considerable decline um
as we go
forward into the summer months and that
means that our daily deaths are now
less than 0.1 per hundred thousand
in each uk nation uh and the final side
please
and this slide shows the number of
people who've received a vaccination for
covid19 in the uk so the total number of
people
cumulatively who've received vaccination
by the 6th of may
and we have given 35.1 million
individuals their first dose and of
these
another 16.8 have received a second dose
so the first those only are the blue
bars
and what you can see now is that orange
bar uh shows the number of
uh individuals who have received both
doses and it is really important at this
point to highlight that if you have had
one dose
do come back for your second dose
because this is likely to boost your
immunity
and keep you safer for longer so a
key message there go and get your job as
the transport secretary has highlighted
this is a really
strong part of the armament in the uk
and is contributing significantly to
those reductions in
hospitalizations and case rates thank
you jenny thanks very much indeed
i'd like to invite paul lincoln director
general border force to talk about our
ports thank you very much transport
secretary i'd like to
start by paying tribute to the thousands
of men and women across border force
who throughout the pandemic have worked
tirelessly to keep the uk
safe and secure all whilst facilitating
legitimate trade and travel
and helping ensure that the uk's
transition from the eu was a smooth one
when i last spoke at one of these press
conferences i said we all look forward
to a time when travel is fully back up
and running and borderforce stands ready
to provide a warm welcome to the uk
but unfortunately we are not back to
normality yet
and today i want to take this
opportunity to take
uh to set out what people can expect to
see at the border
in terms of the new traffic light system
when travel starts to resume
on the 17th of may travel will be
different
and as the transport secretary says we
still need to be cautious
there will continue to be additional
health checks for every person crossing
our border
and inevitably that will mean it will
take longer for most people
to enter the uk these measures have been
put in place
to protect the hard-fought gains and
sacrifices that have been made by
individuals and societies in the uk
minimizing the risks of importing
variants whilst protecting the success
of our vaccine rollout but ensuring the
biosecurity of this country is a joint
effort
as well as border force and wider
government every passenger
every carrier every seaport and every
airport
has a role to play in this endeavor for
the time being
passengers will need to expect an
increase in the time taken
at each stage of their journey
it currently takes a border force
officer 5 to 10 minutes
to complete all the necessary checks
which means even for the most compliant
passenger
it might take 14 or 15 times longer to
process than before
compared to around 25 seconds
and where people do not have the correct
paperwork it can
and has taken considerably longer
including when we need to serve fixed
penalty notices
for non-compliance border force officers
have to date be manually checking
that each person has a valid negative
covert 19 test
and that has been taken within 72 hours
of their journey to the uk
that everyone has also booked a day two
and day eight test package
that those traveling from red countries
have booked into a quarantine hotel
and are handed off to the managed
quarantine service
that those arriving from elsewhere
understand the requirement to quarantine
at home
for 10 days and finally that people have
correctly completed their passenger
locator form
so that they can be contacted by nhs
test and trace
if necessary to keep us all safe
ministers all agree that border force
should check 100
of passengers and we have and will
continue to do so
but we have been taking several steps to
significantly improve and speed up this
process
we are digitizing a number of the checks
just mentioned including the passenger
locator form process
so it can be used in e-gates we are
providing a simpler process
for carriers at check-in and we'll be
increasing the number of border force
officers that are available to process
passengers
at immigration desks we will do all that
we can
to smooth the process and the rollout of
the summer of our e-gate upgrade program
will help minimize the time at the
border for as many people
as possible but the travel industry also
needs to play its part
by making sure that every passenger is
ready for the checks
before they meet the border nonetheless
passengers should still expect times the
borders to take longer
as we conduct the checks that the public
rightly expect
during this global pandemic border force
officers
will deliver the best service possible
but they will also continue the vital
work that they do every day
to protect national security to prevent
drugs
weapons and other illicit goods from
entering the uk
to crack down on illegal migration and
to protect
vulnerable people we all understand
that cues are frustrating to those who
are traveling especially after long
journeys
and with young families and when people
want to return to their loved ones
but if we all play our part in complying
with the health checks
collectively we will also all help to
ensure the safety of our communities
whilst making sure that the gradual
increase in international travel
is as smooth as possible paul thanks
very much
indeed i'd like now to turn to our first
question which comes from david
in west cornwall
keeping the roadmap timetable depends on
the vaccine deployment program
continuing successfully there doesn't
seem to be a shortage in vaccine supply
at present
but might that success be threatened by
a significant shortfall in vaccine
uptake
particularly in the younger age groups
if so
what level of uptake is needed to keep
to the timetable
david thanks very much i'm going to
actually ask jenny's comment on this but
i will just say
the level of uptake has been absolutely
phenomenal um
so far uh i i think it's fair to say
far higher than anyone anticipated when
we were talking about these things
in advance and it's one of the reasons
that the uk has got itself
into this much much better situation
it's important that continues and i'm
going to ask jenny to comment on
the supply and the rest of it thank you
well i think the important thing here is
as as the
transport secretary said we have had a
brilliant uptake in vaccine in this
country and in fact we are probably the
leading
country for vaccine confidence people
are are very
confident to come forward and they
should be and you can see that in the
data that we have around our case rates
this is making a really
strong impact um we have uh we're
guaranteed to offer
uh a first dose of vaccine to every
adult by the end of july there will be
some
um assurance as we go through on the
vaccine production but
we're still on track to do that and of
course we're just coming into
vaccinating the younger age groups the
under 40s so i think it would be wrong
with us to jump to conclusions that the
younger people will not take up the
vaccine they have been
brilliant in stepping forward to comply
for example
students with regulations last autumn so
i think we should just wait and see i
think we have every confidence that
people will step forward
and do that and i think they will be uh
encouraged by the fact that we now have
a long record
of doing so in this country it has been
absolutely
tremendous and long may it continue i'm
going to go to nicola in uh
sorry little says the first two vaccines
were approved for use
very quickly but this process seems to
have stalled for
uh the other potential vaccines and why
well we know that actually a third
vaccine
moderna was also uh approved and i think
in in use but
again jenny you're probably best yes
thank you so i mean the remarkable thing
actually is that we have
three approved vaccines for a new a new
virus within the short time frame that
we have and they have
all undergone the appropriate safety
checks and the continued reporting which
you will see
through mhra i don't think we can say
it's stalled at all
we have good progress through and it's
important of course that each step is
taken
it's not just the the governmental the
scientists that
propose these to go through it's also
when trials are finished
and clearly it's important that we take
note of those studies so i think
other potential vaccines on the way it
varies slightly
across the world but in fact that offer
of the
first vaccine to every adult by the end
of july
should still be in place for the
vaccines that we have i think it's worth
saying as well the vaccine task force
that went out and spent
so much time and energy procuring i
think now i think the velocity i saw was
something like 570
million vaccines has put us in a very
good
position because it means that we've got
a variety of different vaccine
candidates that we're able to
bring in including announcements about
bill uh factories which are producing
more
here including in the north east but a
very much a collective effort
including with the public taking up
vaccines in such large numbers
and just just adding to that of course
one of the other things that is
happening
is around looking to check that we have
vaccines available going forward
against variants of of coronavirus
and investment in public health things
important dan labs there
recently to make sure that we can assess
the effectiveness of
our current vaccines against new
variants which is just as important i
think as what we have currently
thank you to nicola in surrey we'll go
to caroline davis at the bbc next
thank you transport secretary firstly
there are only 12 countries and
territories on this list many passengers
will be very disappointed by that as
will the industry why are there so few
and secondly you put turkey on the red
list what does that mean for the uefa
champions league
final that's due to be played there
thanks very much uh look as i explained
in my
uh in my comments we are having to be
cautious about this initially we don't
want to
overturn all the brilliant work of uh
you know frankly the british people and
taking these uh vaccines and staying at
home and all of that pain and
so we can't do anything to put that at
risk having said that although there are
only 12 countries and territories it
does include
uh for example portugal and uh and uh
some of its islands
uh uh popular uh holiday destinations in
including
israel who will start to accept uh
people from outside the country i think
it's on the 21st
of may but i do accept that it is a
slow but very deliberate uh rollout of
this
and i noted that um heathrow for example
who you might think would jump on your
comments actually agree
that this is the right approach and that
this steady
slow process initially is the right way
to go
it's worth pointing out there are two
separate points at which we'll have
reviews
first of all the joint biosecurity
center will review this data
every three weeks and so we will have
another review
uh point uh along uh uh
pretty pretty soon the second thing to
say is we've got checkpoints built into
this the checkpoints mean that we're
looking at
what has to happen in a green amber
or red in terms of uh the requirements
for testing and so on and so forth so
this will be a fast developing situation
but
really the key thing to say is the
reason there aren't more places on the
list
is there are more places that are in the
fortunate position
that the united kingdom has got itself
in as jenny says people coming forward
vaccines as i was saying
the vaccine task force and the
government um doing such uh
strong work a year ago to make sure we
were ahead
of the world in terms of having those
vaccines so if you're looking for the
answer
it is simply that the rest of the world
needs a bit of time to catch up
with our more fortunate vaccine position
before we'll be able to open up
travel to those locations you ask a very
good question about the uh situation
with regard to
uh uefa and uh the the situation
for uh turkey and as i said in my
comments i'm afraid we are having to put
turkey
on the red list and this will have a
number of ramifications and first of all
uh it does mean i'm afraid with regard
to the champions league that
um fans should not travel to turkey
um the fa i can tell you are in
discussions with uefa
uh already on this uh we are very open
to
hosting uh the the the final but it is
ultimately a decision
for uh uefa uh of course it's worth
mentioning the uk has already got a
successful track record
uh of uh football matches with
spectators
so we're well placed um to do it and i
have spoken to the secretary of state
for
cultural media and sport uh this
afternoon about this so we're very open
to it it is actually in the end a
decision for uefa
uh to make but given that there are two
english clubs
in that final uh we look forward to
hearing what they have to say
thank you very much indeed i'll turn now
to tom clark at itv
thank you secretary of state um while we
worry about where we might be able to
travel to the virus is uh proving it's
pretty capable of traveling into the uk
how concerned are you and should we be
about
the doubling of the number of um
variants of concern originating in
india uh here in the uk and um
how concerned should we be about the
indian variants compared to
those from south africa and brazil for
example so
there are two places to answers one is
of course with the excellent border
protection that paul lincoln and his
team are providing which is helping us
to
keep on top of variants of concern the
second thing is now that the
uh the variant in india is a variant of
concern
rather than a variant of interest which
it has been until uh recently i'm going
to ask jenny to
comment on the epidemiological situation
thank you
um so i think yes we should be concerned
and
i'll come to the action that we're
taking um but there is quite a
complicated message here i think
uh so it's a good sign we've seen the
slides there and our
overall positivity rates have dropped
dramatically
um but in some areas there are some
variants of concern
particularly the indian one which have
risen quite sharply in the last week or
two
so those areas we really do want people
to be extra cautious
again it's important just because that
particular under so the uh the b16172
the about one of the three variants that
we're seeing from india
has increased quite rapidly the other
two the one under the three number
are still variants under interest and
when we move them to a variant of
concern it's because we find something
in how they're behaving or some of
the mutation that we think might give
some cause for concern
either particularly in vaccine escape
severity of disease or transmissibility
now what we have with this particular
indian variant at the moment is
that we found yesterday at the technical
group the variant technical group
that the transmissibility was at least
equal to the
what we've been calling the kemp variant
it's the b117 it's actually very
widespread but people will
recognize it by that name um and we
don't yet know
many other characteristics about it it
takes quite a while to
understand for example the severity of
disease
or what it means for um vaccine
effectiveness so while we're watching
that actually we are taking a whole host
of steps to ensure
that in areas where we have seen that we
have
enhanced contact tracing we're going in
with messaging working with local
communities with local directors of
public health
um to ensure that people are really
aware
of the potential risk we're encouraging
people to continue to work from home all
the things we know
socialize outdoors even if the situation
and the rules change
it's really important people continue to
do that and this is likely to be a bit
of a pattern as we go forward
so we need the public to do everything
that they have been doing
in sticking to the rules but in those
particular areas to be being
particularly careful and we will
continue to monitor it i think one of
the important things is
the uk has absolutely brilliant genomics
we contribute about a third of the total
global genomic sequences that are
um put up on gazette and
so we have a very very clear picture of
what we have in terms of variance of
concern
and under investigation and of course
the the reason why we're
taking uh variants of concern um so
seriously it's one of the reasons in
response to the previous bbc question
that we're not opening up too fast
because we want to be
in a position to control it and it's a
one of the reasons why uh paul lincoln
and his team are checking 100 percent of
people
at borders although that will uh
increasingly on the green list countries
and start to become a digital uh check
through the
e-gate and the passenger locator form
over time
can we go to paul kelso of skye
we can see you there paul i don't know
if you can hear us or not
i can now can you hear me now we're loud
and clear
we know that the travel industry is
desperate to get restarted where i am
is deserted but we've seen already
prices starting to soar
as a result of speculation around this
list and we know travel companies
are declining to offer refunds even for
people with pre-existing
uh reservations the countries on your
orange list does this system
are simply making travel the preserve of
the rich and
if i may with respect a fortnight in the
falklands isn't most eye
people's idea of a summer holiday is it
realistic to think that this year
we will see the return of mass travel to
spain to france
and other really popular destinations as
opposed to this tiny list
of many islands thanks very much
um look paul the first thing is that
it's very important that people do
check the terms and conditions of
booking very very carefully
you mentioned uh travel uh companies and
what people would have called travel
agents perhaps in the past and it is the
case that if you're booking a
uh package for example i've extended the
ability
of people to get uh not just refunds but
also travel vouchers which will be
guaranteed through
the scheme that people know of uh as
atoll
so that a voucher can be given it
perhaps creates a little bit less stress
on the travel company through for those
uh refunds the package holiday
but at the same time provides the
reassurance for
uh consumers whereas previously uh
providing cashback was the only
options the government's tried to back
the industry
in in that sense but it is possible for
people to book direct we do know that
sometimes
uh that that that may lead to problems
and
uh certainly i've had a lot plenty of
people in the last year contact me
in that position so please check very
very carefully
when it comes to terms and conditions
and i i note now that a lot of the
travel companies and a lot of the
airlines have put some very smart
packages in place
enabling people to change for example
the time of their flight the date of
their flight without uh cost for
doing so but check secondly uh does it
become the reserve of the reach and do
you want a
holiday in in the in the falklands uh
there are other locations
uh on there uh although i'm sure that
auckland's is is lovely um
but look this is not a list generated
and created
um to if you like um
think about where people want to lie on
beaches and then twist the science
uh to fit it that would be completely
wrong
it would go against everything that we
have said about
uh in fact it would betray the the sort
of
um what everyone has gone through for
the last year the sacrifices that people
have made staying home going to get the
vaccine when called the enormous
national
uh effort if we were then to throw it
all away and just say we'll add some
holiday destinations on we cannot do
that and i hope
people will i think people will
appreciate and understand that
what we can and will do though is review
the list
very regularly and jenny will correct me
if i'm wrong but
you mentioned 12 fatalities
deaths per day on a seven day running
average
when i came in i checked where france is
at i think it's about 220
fatalities per day we just need to give
other places in the world a chance to
catch up and some of those places
are the locations where people want to
go on holiday so to answer your
last question about whether we'll see
mass travel
uh or not uh look i think we will
gradually see
an opening up we see that the uh the
um the vaccines are extremely effective
but what we can't do and what we don't
know is the extent to which
somebody who is vaccinated might still
be capable of
carrying a variant of concern
back with them and we cannot put the
british people at risk in that way
so it's a gentle gradual thing as i
mentioned before heathrow
and others uh are welcoming uh the steps
today
it is a first step but it's a very
deliberate one with some clear review
points in there as well jenny i don't
know if there's anything
i think you've you've mentioned all the
important things it it is just really
important as you said earlier that we
progress with necessary
caution um and you can see i mean i
think
the public will have realized just from
looking at the picture in india
just how quickly uh virus can take off
particularly if there is
low vaccine coverage in those countries
or you have
a large number of people without spacing
and all of the things that we've got
used to doing
so obviously that varies significantly
across the world but there is a regular
review point the joint biosecurity
center
has a very detailed exploration of all
of the
different criteria so whether it be
testing
capacity whether it be the capability of
a country to
look at the genome sequencing a whole
host of things that we didn't have last
year so i think
a lot of reassurance that all of this is
looking at looked at in great detail
and as countries are able to move into
those different traffic light areas
then ministers will be able to make
those decisions i think it's worth
actually
saying as jenny uh hinted at um the
joint biosecurity center last year would
use
pretty blunt information really it was
about the number of cases per hundred
thousand
uh over a seven day uh period this year
it's about
not just the prevalence of cases it's
about the variance of concern
it's about the ability of the country to
test
the quality of their data how good their
genome sequencing
is and i think reassuringly uh paul
all of that's going to be published this
year both the methodology
and the data so people can see
themselves how and why
the particular countries and territories
that are being included at the moment
are in there and i think that will be
helpful for everyone
thanks very much paul can we go to lucy
fisher of the telegraph
thank you two quick questions if i may
firstly
for mr lincoln will board a force deploy
more staff
to ease delays at the border and if so
how many
and secondly a question for the
transport secretary please
vaccinated britons are allowed to travel
to other countries without having to
take expensive covert tests
or quarantine but the uk government
insists on these measures
from vaccinated travelers why doesn't
the government have faith in the vaccine
and will this policy be reviewed thanks
very much
lucy paul yes thank you lucy i mean um
we will and i said in my opinion
statement that we will be increasing the
number of border force officers
who will be uh available to process
passengers at immigration desks
i mean i should put this in the context
that um there are currently at the
moment
more border force officers processing
passengers at heathrow
than any other time since 2012 olympics
and the reason why
uh people talk about this is because we
have had to deal with a lot of
non-compliant passengers
and that sometimes takes border force
officers away so what i'm very pleased
to have announced today is the
simplification of the processes we've
put in place
which should make it easier for
passengers should make it easier for
carriers it should make it easier for
our officers
and do our best to speed people through
the border thanks very much
in answer to your second point about
vaccinated brits being allowed to
travel to other countries actually when
i look around the world and as i
mentioned in my comments i chaired a
meeting of the
g7 the group of seven uh secretaries of
state for transport
uh in the week uh and actually um they
don't have systems
in place for uh travel yet they
haven't launched their equivalence of
the global travel task force nor do they
have
traffic light systems actually by and
large we because we
have managed to vaccinate a higher
proportion of the population
faster than other countries we're also
ahead in terms of this unlock program
both the
wider road map of which the 17th of may
and the 21st of
uh june are the third and fourth moments
but also in terms of
unlocking uh travel but you ask a really
interesting question about
well if you've been double vaccinated
you know why shouldn't you be able to
uh go uh travel and it's a question of
course we're asking
all the time and again actually i'm
going to to lean on uh
advice here from uh jenny because i
think it's one of the things uh
the questions that scientists are having
to tackle most at the moment
so uh thank you so i think from uh what
what i've said previously uh
we are learning a lot about the vaccines
so we're very confident that for most
variants out there at the moment the
vaccines that we're using
will prevent protect the individual from
serious disease
and from hospitalization we think also
that there is a degree
of effectiveness in vaccine transmission
and there was some media on that i think
at the beginning
of last week however there are two
particular points one is
that is not a complete picture so some
people will
all vaccine programs actually that will
not work for every single individual so
we encourage as many people as possible
to reduce the the chance of
uh of disease being around but we don't
yet have
absolute clarity i think on the
transmission risk
and that continues to be the case as new
variants
arise so we know as i said previously
there are thousands of variants
um and we every now and again they're
not all of significance many will appear
and die down again and be of no concern
at all
but the south african variant of course
we've done uh that has
risen a little bit in the uk but has
been reasonably contained
each of these actually suggests that
there is a little lowering of the effect
of the vaccine in that case
and each new variant we're looking to
make sure that vaccines continue to be
effective so as a new variant arises if
you're going over to another country
particularly if they have lower
genomic sequencing capabilities they're
very unlikely to know what they have in
their population
and individuals will potentially bring
it back to this one
and one of the important points i would
just like to make is when travellers are
coming back
it is absolutely critical that they have
their
early tests their pcr test so they have
one before
they leave the other country they must
if they're positive they must comply
with local
isolation regulations but when they come
back into this country
they must have a pcr test up to
day two so in that very early phase what
that does is firstly
we know whether they are sick and
whether they need to isolate but
actually they are contributing not just
to the uk knowledge about the growth of
variants from different countries
but to the global knowledge about it so
we can sequence where others can't
we contribute that information to global
knowledge um and then the whole world
learns to protect themselves better so
really important to have that test
thanks very much jenny and lucy i just
say we've come so far
we just don't want to mess this up now i
think would be the shorthand for
all of that and the scientists are
working hard on
getting the hard data to back it up
thank you very much
if i can go to torquel creighton from
the daily record please
thank you minister can you provide some
clarity
you talk about travelers from england
and your press release talks about
england you don't have four nations
agreement for this by the
by the sounds of it and and if you don't
it's a bit of a fascism
if if i have a reader in fife who wants
to go to pharaoh
and they're not allowed to travel from a
scottish airport they just jump on a
train
to to heathrow and they did they jump a
red light it undermines the
the uk for nation approaching foreign so
first of all i should let you know that
i've uh
i held a call with the devolved
administrations earlier today
and all of the four chief medical
officers of the joint
biosecurity center have met and agreed
the principles that sit behind the
traffic light
system so there is a large degree of uh
agreement and uh cooperation in
developing the system i think more to
your point there happened to be
elections
uh on or rather election counts uh in uh
wells and um
scotland at the moment and so
understandably
whilst those governments are uh in
influx
uh uh and there aren't effective
opposite numbers to to speak to
it may take a few days for uh them to uh
prescribe is precisely
what they wish to do but it is with
their uh agreement that the
if you like the traffic light system
itself has been uh created
uh and as we saw uh last year i suspect
that by and large we'll see
the same conclusions for the simple
reason uh that the
the science is the science and the
epidemiological situation is that that
presents us
uh presents to us all and since we're
working from the same traffic light
system
it stands to reason it will be uh
broadly uh
similar in design so
that is the that's the the picture we
look forward to there being governments
in
police uh in both wales uh and scotland
uh and uh uh to having a as joined up a
picture as possible just on your final
point though
i would say what you sort of pointed out
is it's possible for people to break the
law
of course it's possible people break the
law in all sorts of uh different
ways but people should respect the law
as it is legislated
uh in our uh devolved uh system of
government throughout the four nations
and so we must never encourage anybody
to
as you describe it break the law jump on
a train and do something uh which they
should not be doing and presumably would
carry
um some pretty big fines uh if they were
to do so
thanks very much i'll turn now to jim
scott at the northern echo
jim thank you as the country exits the
national lockdown and as more
restrictions are eased
there will inevitably be an increase in
cases but if there is a spike in covered
infections in one particular region such
as the northeast
is the government likely to consider
preventing residents in that area from
traveling abroad
we've come out as we come out of this
lockdown we've got this
four stage road map and as you as you
know
will have noted we haven't gone back
into a tiered um situation
that's possible actually because overall
our levels are so much
lower and where they're low overall
where the prevalence is
is low you're able to take a much more
national
approach to all of this and i very much
um hope jim and i'm going to ask
jenny to comment uh but we're not going
back uh to those
bad old days of very high levels of
enormous prevalence and the rest of it
because we've got the one thing that we
didn't have
when we got down to these very low uh
levels uh last time round and that is of
course
the vaccine actually i said the one
that's the second thing which is mass
testing
every adult in this country every
secondary child in this country
can have two tests a week free delivered
to their
homes and millions of people are taking
up that offer and it's helping to us to
us to identify
where there are problems so we are much
better positioned this year with
vaccines with testing with genomic
sequencing uh to not need to take that
localized uh approach and so far
um so good but i'm going to hand over to
an expert here
no it's it's a really important question
but i think the ambition is exactly as
the transport secretary has said
um that we know that there have been
certain areas which i think we now
would frame as where there has been
enduring transmission and it's those
populations
who have really had to be locked down
for very lengthy periods of time and
that's not just
unhelpful for them and a bit miserable
for them during that time but actually
it will affect the health of those
populations in the longer term as well
if they've had
higher rates of of cover potentially
long covered implications
and uh implications for uh the viability
and the health of their families long
term so miss school and all sorts of
things
so i think our approach at the moment is
to actually really focus
on those areas of enduring transmission
in a number of ways working with
directors of public health and local
authorities
there are a number of different
community testing programs so that where
we see those higher rates
to go in to help support individuals to
find
infections and to help them to isolate
many of these families are ones were
perhaps where
they're more likely to have to go out to
work or they're in larger families it's
less easy to isolate and there are a
number of ways
uh which local authorities can can
support them
with central government funding through
a communities
fund to do that but it's a really good
point and it is actually our focus of
attention as we come
out of the lockdowns and really focus
as we go forward and once again just
encourage if if
individuals are in areas where there are
variants of concern
ready to be extra careful in those until
those rates have subsided
jenny thanks very much indeed i just
wanted to end by saying you know i could
never have imagined when i became
secretary of state for transport that i
would be
responsible for locking down all
international travel indeed most of the
domestic travel
network as well and i'm pleased that
we're finally in the position of opening
up i've been looking forward to
today or a day like today for a very
long time but
we do have to follow a very cautious
approach we've got to follow the science
at every step we don't want to throw
away the very hard-won
uh gains but i think as confidence
builds as the rest of the world
is able to catch up with our successful
vaccination
program and get themselves vaccinated i
expect that we will see a situation
where
more countries will open up but please
check the details carefully
look on gov dot uk and make sure that
you have refundable
options and most of all of course remain
safe thank you very much
thank you quant chap said the transport
secretary announcing the first green
list 12 countries
that people will be able to visit
without quarantining if they test
on departure and arrival including
portugal israel
australia new zealand perhaps not
massively helpful those
last two because they're currently not
allowing international travelers
there was also three additions to the
red list the maldives nepal and turkey
that final one quite interesting because
of course istanbul the venue for the
champions league final could that be
moved with two
english teams in it well let's bring in
uh paul caso shall we our correspondent
who had a question
at that press conference so a slow
return
to some international travel but it
won't be anything like as we know it
yeah indeed it's entirely in keeping
with the tone that's been set
domestically by the prime minister and
the government in terms of
moving out of lockdown stage by stage we
were not expecting this
to be a big reveal of lots of countries
that many of us
would have high on our list of holiday
destinations and it wasn't it was a
a very short list relatively speaking 12
states none of which i think sophie from
our quick
check that we've been able to do since
the secretary of state got to his feet
none of which are currently
admitting britain so until that changes
uh the fact you'll be able to travel to
them will be something of a theoretical
exercise though we may see perhaps some
reciprocal
arrangements emerging portugal the one
that most people might be thinking of as
a regular holiday
destination it was interesting that the
secretary of state was very
keen to stress that this was a rigorous
process
based on evidence following the science
uh a phrase we've heard
before they talk about the role of the
joint biosecurity center in setting
the parameters over here the things
they're looking at we know
how widespread is the vaccine coverage
in the destination countries what are
the covered rates perhaps most crucially
of all
how good are they detecting variants
and that's why this list is short when i
asked him whether it was uh
realistic to expect the big ticket
countries the places
so many people go spain france uh turkey
greece and like to end up on the green
list he did say it was realistic but
it was striking that he said we're not
choosing places you want to go and lie
on a sun lounger and then twisting the
science to fit
round it so clearly the position is the
message very clearly is
i really don't want us traveling uh
traveling certainly as little
as possible and uh there's certainly not
much choice there
but one wonders what happens to internet
searches for flights and cruises to
uh the south atlantic with the falklands
and south georgia
on that list paul kelsey thank you very
much
indeed um i just want to quickly
bring you a result from northeast wales
wrexham because it does seem
like there's a different picture
emerging in wales and england
when it comes to the labour party
performance let's have a look
at this result now it's a labor hold you
can see there labor
winning wrexham with a majority of 1
350. now this is
interesting because really the
conservatives were expected to take the
seat from labour they won the equivalent
constituency in the 2019 general
election was a key brick in the red bull
that
turned blue have a quick look at uh the
share of the vote
i think we've got for you uh labor there
winning 37.4 percent of the vote in
wrexham
31.4 going to the conservatives and this
is a change in share
so pretty static uh there between labour
and the conservatives uh sam coats uh
deputy political editor with me
signs that some labour doing a bit
better in wales than they are in england
that's right i mean if you look at those
numbers on the screen just there it's
quite rare in
today to see the labor losses less than
the tory losses
uh albeit by half a percentage point um
yes i think that
labour advisers are slightly relieved
that wales isn't going
worse um with 13 seats declared
uh labour have 39 percent of the vote
and the tories 29 implied
on 22 so it doesn't seem to be the kind
of disaster that we're seeing in
england remember wales is a list system
it is incredibly complicated because
gains in the constituency section are
then uh undone in the list section so
it's very early to say how how this will
turn out in the wash
interesting stuff certainly want to take
a look out for and not
just apply the same blanket rules across
the whole of the united kingdom
now let's just find out quickly what the
travel industry is making of the
transport secretary's
announcement today we can go live to
leicestershire and talk to claire james
who is the managing director of east
midlands airport are you happy with
today's announcement
uh disappointed to to be honest with you
it's a start but it's not what we'd
hoped for
we had hoped to see more on the green
list
and so yes it's a start
but a disappointing one and you say that
you're hoping to see more countries on
the green list but is it not right that
the government takes a cautious
approach for now absolutely we've always
maintained that public health is the
priority
but given the success of the vaccine
rollout
given our ability to test and given the
falling case rates
in other destinations we felt that list
could have been bigger without being
detrimental or putting the public health
at risk what kind of countries were you
hoping might be added to it then
the canaries some of the greek islands
we we've seen the low case rates i think
what we're lacking here is transparency
around the criteria
you know what are the case numbers
they're looking for what
what are the testing criteria in those
destination countries
what are the surveillance capabilities
we're not clear on how the government
are making these assessments
and that's what we need to know and the
public need confidence to be able to
book and know what's coming
how difficult are things for the
industry now
what's pretty clear is we're not going
to see an easy return to international
travel for some time even if there is
this
gradual reopening of the sector
the impact on the aviation industry has
been definitely
devastating it's the worst event in our
history
to be honest with you um so you know
we've seen passenger numbers over the
last year
at less than 20 of pre-covered levels
it goes back to needing clarity and
certainty
and clarity around testing procedures as
well so that consumers can book with
confidence we know the demand's there we
know people want to go
on holiday to visit family to visit
friends
and we need to make the process clear
and the criteria clear
so we people can have a summer holiday
um what um kind of criteria do you think
there should be do you think should be
based on vaccination do you think should
be based on case rape what kind of
things should be considered
i think you know the government's right
they've got that criteria we know that
testing is part of this we know that
vaccinations are part of this
but but let's be clear you know our
european counterparts
are quickly catching up they're a few um
weeks behind us
so what we could now do is is signpost
those destinations
so people can book with confidence what
what the industry really struggles with
is uncertainty and we need time to plan
the airlines need time to plan
as do people from a booking perspective
okay thank you very much for
coming on the program and giving us your
reaction to that downing street
press conference you're watching sky
news lots more coming up on the
elections that have been taking place
across england scotland and wales we're
going to be hearing sikkim stama's
reaction to labour's
poor showing in the local elections
particularly
at those english councils and of course
the hartlepool
by-election how does he intend to turn
it around
we'll be trying to find out